so Matthew how are you not great you
know nothing in my life is going in the
direction I wanted to be going sorry um
Matthew Kim thanks can I interrupt you
right here I don't think you're doing as
badly as you think you're doing if I may
tell you about some of the other
patients I see I know I'm not supposed
to because of doctor-patient
confidentiality but I think it might
help you sure like this one guy is he
right real loser lives with his mother
but to make him feel like a big man he
pays her rent but it's like $30
it's like pretend rent I like oh he'll
mommy mommy I'm a big boy I pay the rent
I work at a job and I pay you the way
here you go make me a PB&J because I'm a
wittle [ __ ] I'm a little [ __ ] and I
live under the stairs like hell we patio
house man really
yeah we talked about her last week I
explained to you the rent system that my
mother and I worked out and you said it
was a step in the right direction and it
is it is you're doing great and hey at
least you're not doing as bad as this
other guy see he has a wreck tile
dysfunction but like aggressive erectile
dysfunction he can't even get hard for
himself he's all Twinkie no cream I'll
limp no biscuit I put him in the
appointment book a soggy noodle that was
me
oh I had a SOG nude that's why I how's
that going you told me it was normal and
I had nothing to worry about it is and
you don't you know it's good I think
we're making real progress here yeah and
listen at least you're not as bad as
this one guy see he misses his
girlfriend so much he dresses a pillow
that he sleeps with in an old t-shirt
and that was you once man hmm can't stop
huffing liquid paper me can't poop
unless he's listening to jock jams I was
being sexually attracted to the oldest
Keebler Elf I was me secretly by can't
stop looking at capped buttholes likes
to burn his own pubes with a Bic lighter
me me me can't have sex unless there's
50 pairs of underwear in the room
no that's not me you're not as bad as
that guy yeah what a loser
that one's me I need 50 not including my
own
that's her time see you next week leave
your undies thanks noodle